this little e-cigarette made Jewel Labs
one of the most valuable startups in
Silicon Valley in 2018.
at its peak the company was worth 38
billion dollars Jules popularity swelled
as U.S cigarette sales fell
it even spawned a verb juling and it had
upended the entire tobacco industry
today its future is in doubt Jewel has
narrowly escaped bankruptcy laid off
nearly three-quarters of its workers and
one of its largest shareholders divested
its 35 stake
now it's in limbo waiting to see if it
can continue selling its products so
what went wrong
the first Jewel Vaporizer was released
in 2015. its stated Mission eliminate
traditional cigarettes
some early reviews were positive The
Jewel from Pax might be the best
designed e-cigarette out there following
its release e-cigarette use jumped among
teens while use of other tobacco
products declined thanks largely to the
popularity of Jewel it had this cool
sort of sleek device that looked like a
USB charger it was unlike anything that
had come before it was sort of like the
apple of e-cigarettes
Jules early ad campaign in 2015 featured
young people puffing and partying and
flavors like mint and mango appeal to
younger users I've never been exposed to
Tobacco why would I try it but since I
was exposed to fruit obviously and mango
and mint that I just thought it was okay
Jewel
the e-cigarette brand of choice in 2018
Jewel was dominating the e-cigarette
Market its sales were soaring and it was
the number one e-cigarette brand
but in April of that year the FDA
started taking a closer look at the
product's appeal to teens
facing that probe and mounting criticism
Jules said it would stop selling
flavored refill pods in an effort to
stem underage use as a mom of teenagers
it is certainly a step in the right
direction at least they could do then in
December despite these concerns the
biggest tobacco company in the U.S
Altria the parent company of Philip
Morris USA took a 35 stake in the
startup Altria saw smokers switching to
vaping and its own e-cigarettes couldn't
match Jules popularity
it paid 12.8 billion dollars for its
stake valuing Jewel at 38 billion
dollars but the deal only increased
regulatory scrutiny on the company we
are in the midst of a youth vaping
epidemic Regulators started looking at
altria's investment and the FDA the
Federal Trade Commission and Attorneys
General across the country were all
still investigating Jules marketing
practices and so we have a
responsibility as the chief law
enforcement officer in the state of New
York to protect young people and that's
what we are doing with this litigation
as the U.S cracked down on the
e-cigarette industry and Jewel
voluntarily stopped most of its
marketing Jewels sales and market share
fell
in 2021 Joel reported a net loss of 259
million dollars and an 11 decline in
sales according to a disclosure the
company made to employees Jewell said it
was working to regain the Public's Trust
then in June 2022 the FDA dealt Jewel a
major blow Jewel electronic cigarettes
can no longer be sold in the U.S the
agency ordered Jewel to pull its
Products off of U.S shelves but not for
alleged marketing to teens according to
FDA documents viewed by The Wall Street
Journal Jewell hadn't sufficiently
answered the agency's questions about
whether Jules products might expose
users to chemicals that could pose a
health risk Jewel immediately appealed
and the FDA issued a stay on the order
which means that Jules products were
allowed to remain on the market pending
an appeal in July the FDA said it would
allow Jewel to continue selling products
in the U.S its most important Market by
this point underage vaping had fallen
and Jewel was no longer the number one
e-cigarette brand among teens it wasn't
even in the top 10.
Jewel was soon facing bankruptcy it was
unclear whether Jules products were
going to be able to remain on the market
or would have to be pulled off
and because its future was unclear Jewel
suddenly was unable to take out
traditional loans or get Investments
that would help cover the cost of its
legal liabilities and some of these
lawsuits were scheduled to come up soon
for trial in November Jewell said it had
secured financing to avoid bankruptcy
its saviors came in the form of Hyatt
Hotels Heir Nick pritzker and California
investor Riaz vilani these two men
basically gave Jewel a Lifeline they
gave Joel a cash infusion to help Jewel
stay afloat and cover some of these
legal settlements Jewel announced plans
to lay off a third of its Global staff
leaving the company with a fraction of
the 3 000 workers it had in 2019 and a
month later pritzker and vilani helped
Jewel make another big step the company
agreed to pay 1.7 billion dollars in a
broad legal settlement covering more
than 5 000 lawsuits over marketing to
teens Jewel denied wrongdoing it really
helped clarify Jules future with those
lawsuits hanging over it its future had
been somewhat in doubt and so it was
able to resolve the bulk of the legal
liability that it faced fast forward to
March 2023 when Altria divested its
minority stake in Jewel at a loss of at
least 12.5 billion dollars the fact that
Altria was a big shareholder in Jewel
meant that Jewel did not have complete
freedom to enter into new investment
agreements with other parties jewel is
has complete freedom to
um either you know come up with
distribution agreements
um new investment agreements or sell the
company outright to someone else on
April 12th Jewell agreed to pay 462
million dollars to settle lawsuits filed
by six states and the District of
Columbia
five days later it settled its last
pending lawsuit the declining health and
well-being of millions of teens and
young adults will not be a footnote in
Jules business plans today Jules future
is uncertain the big question remains
what is the FDA going to say and decide
about whether its products can remain on
the market if its products do have to
come off the market it would need a
Lifeline of some sort to keep going
thank you